The speed of light is a constant,
but the important thing about variables in Python is that they can vary.
That's why they're called "variables."
Once we define a variable, we can change the value.
Then when we use that name again, it refers to the new value.
Let's see that in the interpreter. We could change the values of cycles&#95;per&#95;second.
Suppose we have a faster processor.
Now we've upgraded. We've got a 2.8 GHz processor.
Now, that doesn't affect the value of cycle&#95;distance.
This was already computed with the old cycles per second.
We still get the result 0.111.
We'll compute it again.
This time the value of cycles&#95;per&#95;second is the new value,
since we changed what cycles&#95;per&#95;second refers to.
Now, when we print cycle&#95;distance, we see that the value is changed.
So we have a faster processor the second time we print cycle&#95;distance.
Now we only have 0.107 meters--less than 11 cm per cycle.
What happens now that we have assignment,
the same expression can have different meanings different times we evaluate it.
The value of this speed&#95;of&#95;light divided by cycles&#95;per&#95;second
depends on what the current value of cycles&#95;per&#95;second is.
When we evaluate the first one the value was 2,700,000,000.
We got a different result, which is the 0.111 result we got the first time.
When we evaluate the same expression the second time the result is different,
because the value that cycles&#95;per&#95;second refers to is different,
and that's why we get the smaller cycle distance the second time.
So let's see what's going on there and make sure we understand the assignment.
Suppose we have a variable "days," and we'll initialize it to the value 7 x 7.
What that does is introduce the name "days" and refers to a value,
which is the result of that expression, so it refers to the value 49.
That means when we look up the name "days," we see what it refers to,
and we get the result 49.
If we do another assignment, let's say we have one less day.
In this case, we'll assign 48 to "days."
That's a new assignment. We already have a name "days."
It used to refer to 49 but after the new assignment,
it's going to refer to this new value.
Now it's going to refer to the value 48.
The number 49 still exists, but "days" no longer refers to it.
Now "days" refers to 48.
Where things get more interesting is we can use variables in their own assignment statements.
Here we have an assignment statement where we have the value "days - 1,"
and we assign that to "days". What happens with that assignment?
Well, we evaluate the right side first.
We look for the value of days, and we see that it refers to 48.
We compute "days - 1," and we get the value 47.
Then we do that assignment that will assign to the variable "days."
Now the value "days" refers to the value 47--no longer refers to 48.
So we could keep doing that.
If we did another statement, the same exact one. That's going to change the value again.
The first time the value "days" is 47.
We'll subtract 1. We'll get the value 46. Then we do the assignment.
That'll change the value so now "days" refers to the value 46.
The important thing to notice--this is not an equal symbol.
This looks like an equal symbol.
If you studies algebra, you would think an equation like this looks like an equality,
and there is no way to solve an equation like that.
In Python and in most programming language, "=" does not mean equal.
What "=" means is assignment.
You should really think of it as an arrow.
It's an arrow saying put whatever the value the right side evaluates to
into the name on the left side.
We don't write it as an arrow in most programming languages.
(there are some that do) just because an arrow is harder to type,
and lots of programs have lots of assignments.
But you should think of the equal sign as not meaning equal. It means "assignment."